juani hablemos ahora el fútbol femenino
así es raúl volvió la liga de campeones
femenina el país vasco en españa acoge
la final a 8 de la competición que
estaba suspendida desde los octavos de
final que se disputaron en octubre el
wolfsburgo alemán goleó 9 a 1 al glasgow
seri en anoeta por su parte el barcelona
que fue finalista de la temporada pasada
venció por la mínima al atlético de
madrid en bilbao este sábado del arsenal
se mide ante el psg y el lyon que son
los vigentes tetracampeones las vigentes
tetracampeón as se enfrentan al bayern
recordemos que de las principales ligas
europeas femeninas sólo la alemana se
mantuvo en competición en medio de la
pandemia